we have tended to use new technologies
and companies in two ways either to
lower costs or to create more effective
ways of approaching the market the using
technology merely to lower operational
costs amounts to standing on a whale
fishing for minnows it just allows you
to do the old thing more efficiently
we're in this moment of deep
transformation it is much more likely
that you should be doing something
entirely new in an entirely different
way so if you focus on technology solely
as a way to squeeze expense out of your
existing business you're probably doing
it at the cost of ignoring what your
future business will be so my advice is
don't use technology primarily to lower
costs use technology to create new
effective ways of touching the market
and creating new businesses and if you
do that right the cost savings will come